today we're also mourning the loss of  Jerry Stiller let's Rumble Ben Stiller  tweeted that he lost his 92 year old dad  to quote natural causes he was a great  dad and grandfather and the most  dedicated husband to and for about 62  years he will be greatly missed love you  dad  your kid does things that you never  thought you could do now I go the movies  free the rest of my life isn't that nice  et was with the actor and late wife and  Mara throughout the 80s and 90s after  their own success as a comedy duo then  Jerry landed his unforgettable Seinfeld  role as George Costanza stir fry and I  was not aware of the popularity of the  show was born I get happy Festivus even  when it's springtime you're the  laughingstock of the entire fashion  world from Zoolander with son Ben to the  king of queens will never forget the  laughs thanks charity just gonna be my  my legacy is this what they're gonna say  about me for the rest of my life okay  where's my boy oh my god  you